Now that we have a sense of what inventory is,...
...let's get into why it's important to account for it properly.
At its most basic level, when you understand how much inventory you have,...
...how much it cost you, and how much you're selling it for, plus when it's selling,...
...you can gain insights to help you make smarter business decisions.
Working out your profit margins...
...will help you figure out which products are earning you the most money,...
...versus which products just aren't worth it.
This can help you identify what types of products to focus on...
...if you want to grow your business.
Inventory accounting can also help you understand your seasonal sales cycles.
What sells better in summer compared to what sells in the winter?
You want to have enough stock on hand...
...so you don't run out of popular items during their season,...
...but not so much that all your cash is tied up in goods...
...that customers won't want again for several months.